I invited my neighbor from nbc's
california live a fellow Texan I love
her and American Idol alum to be here
and help us navigate through this sticky
time okay
it's welcome mom on a mission Kimberly
Caldwell hard okay you're a mom yes you
get it right it where's my mom's [ __ ]
down there yeah okay so with Halloween
just around the corner so I teamed up
with a really good friend of mine her
name is dr. Daphne dude okay
she's a pediatrician she's very very
important and he's a pediatrician she's
a master mom of children's nutrition she
gave me all this expertise that you know
I didn't know so I decided to share it
with all you guys and y'all can do
whatever you want to do with the
information I'm not here to judge I have
all the information and I literally fed
my daughter donuts for breakfast this
morning you're like I mean I was gonna
say I fed both of my daughters donuts
for breakfast this morning and so I'm
not a really big fan of learning I know
mom of the year so I've decided to play
a little game it's a true or false game
okay but it's the Kelly Clarkson show so
it's yes ma'am no ma'am I love it
alright let's find out if you're as bad
a parent as I am you're ready for art
yes ma'am yes alright so are you ready
for some master mom ends up like that
mommy I like it you did there sugar is
as addictive as recreational drugs yes
and I actually think it's more addictive
and I am actually a walking example yes
ma'am you're not gonna get your kids
drugs but research shows that sugar is
as addictive as cocaine ok eating sugary
foods like candy chocolate increases
chemicals in your brain called dopamine
dopamine dopamine which gives us that
feel-good high so every time that we eat
sugar we have to eat more sugar I know
and guess what that's called
to get the same high my life what it's
called it's also called addiction
addiction addiction oh I have a little
solution okay so this Halloween instead
of feeding we're all gonna go
trick-or-treating let's get over it
instead of feeding them the entire
bucket or letting them have it
my daughter just turned 4 yesterday
happy birthday Harlow so she just turned
4 so she gets 4 pieces
me and Kelly are 21 we get 21 pieces
again is 21
one now that childlike sailor yes on
average children under 12 consume almost
25 pounds of sugar a year yes ma'am or
no ma'am
what that's a lot yes ma'am
actually they do not consume 25 pounds
of sugar more I knew it it's a no ma'am
they consume almost 50 pounds of sugar
on average and that's actually basically
just like cancer that's more than us we
only consume only 46 pounds of sugar a
year can you believe that I know I'm
driving home down relateable ride okay
here's the great thing you guys I love
this you can do a good deed
this Halloween and send all of your
leftover candy to soldiers angels treats
for troops program two deployed service
members and veterans
I love it I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this